Подавати податкову декларацію у Німеччині,
на відміну від України, громадянам вигідно.
Оскільки можна повернути значну суму податків –
у середньому близько тисячі євро.
Тому щорічну декларацію подає навіть багато тих,
кого закон не зобов’язує це робити.
Повернути частину податків можна за такі витрати.
Якщо через роботу вам довелось переїжджати,
можна повернути податки із вартості за перевезення речей,
квитків на літак, плати ріелтору,
який допоміг знайти нове житло тощо.
Також можна списати податки за ремонтні роботи у новій хаті.
Податки на витрати на ноутбук, принтер,
іншу техніку, придбані для виконання вашої роботи,
також можна частково компенсувати.
У цей список можна додати навіть костюм для співбесіди
чи для дотримання дрескоду на новій роботі,
а також витрати на діловий ланч із клієнтами.
Дуже важливо довести , що всі ці речі
і справді були потрібні для роботи,
інакше податкова може не взяти їх до уваги.
Якщо ви навчаєтесь якоїсь професії,
податкова може повернути певну суму зборів за навчання.
Наприклад, за дорогу до університету.
Так само компенсуються відвідування виставок,
потрібні для перепідготовки працівника.
Податки з оплати няні, бебісітера
інших витрат на дитину також можна відшкодувати.
Навіть якщо з дитиною сидять бабуся або дідусь,
повернути можна їхні витрати на дорогу до онука.
З ваших благодійних внесків та пожертв,
наприклад до Червоного хреста чи Всесвітнього фонду дикої природи,
також можна списати податки.
Головне - зберігати квитанції про перерахунок коштів.
Враховуючи всі ці аспекти,
в результаті можна отримати непогану суму.
Подавати декларацію за попередній рік
німці мають до 31 травня.
А непідзвітні податковій громадяни
можуть зробити це і до кінця року.